[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants vous êtes vous bien
amusé aujourd'hui moi je me suis ennuyée
patron je manque de moore et bien pour
faire plaisir à nounours vous savez ce
que vous allez faire vous allez danser
avec lui vous en avez de bonnes idées
mais pourvu que nicolas et pimprenelle
que ton vie de tension avec moi descend
vite leurs demandes et ne dansent j'y
cours
mon seul l'europe populaire c'est un
jardin tu fais pas un chapeau bas vous
j'ai besoin de mouvement j'ai envie de
danser
voulez-vous danser avec moi mais d'abord
regarde déjà les chatons que j'ai fait
pour ma poupée
m
elbow van tu verras bessan comme ça en
bien qu'il est fait pour toi
bon alors on embauche nous faisons une
ronde louis et menus semaines au mieux
nous allons faire les neurones ne pourra
miser tout le monde mademoiselle en
présentant ce fait nous la référence
faite à tous de mythos embrasser tous
vos amis
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
lalala
alors là là là
la la la
la lan nous allons faire une euro ne
pourra mesure où le mot de mademoiselle
en présentant ce fait nous la référence
faite à 12 me touche en voici tous vos
amours là
[Musique]
et à présent mes petits amours voilà une
annonce qui fera qu'on s'est promis en
l'air on de jacques renonce ne dément
qui sait et moi l'homme j'éteins la
lumière
bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants vous avez bien danser
nous nous sommes amusés comme des fous
patron ce que tu es mignon aux nounours
tu t'habilles comme une poupée à présent
que je suis toujours dit c'est le
chapeau de pop rondelle au vol alors en
route gros étourdi route
bonne nuit des enfants fait de beauvais
e
[Musique]